much of the work is quite technical
and it's being done
at record speed but without sacrificing
the safety of the ships
and the seafarers on board them
this is an encouraging sign for the
forward
the agreement is scheduled to last for
120 days
and we still have much work ahead of us
to ensure that the implementation of
initiative translates into real results
to address food insecurity around the
globe and to stabilize global food
markets
we are off to a very good start in terms
of ships uh not being excited about
going in i think
we have seen tremendous interest from
ship owners in terms of uh uh
their willingness to make this transit
uh but what they needed was the
procedures so that they would know what
to do now we've released those and we're
expecting to see
a big up tip uptick in applications for
transit indeed we're aware that there
are a number of
empty grain vessels
sitting at anchorage in turkish
anchorage areas waiting to arrange the
contracts uh and once they have their
deals arranged they'll be transiting
northbound 370 000 metric tons uh in
what is real the initial phase of this
operation uh i think is is a very
encouraging sign
and the goal of getting between two and
five metric tons uh is achievable and
then the wfp ship what's taking it so
long it was the
just to the question
well i you know i think uh
regardless of it whether it's wfp or
really any entity it it's quite a
complicated operation to put together a
voyage for a ship to carry cargo you've
got to arrange
for crew you've got to find a ship
you've got to get the appropriate
clearances which also includes clearance
to transit uh the boss first straight
so there are a number of steps involved
and we're aware of many entities uh
including the wfp that are working on
that but in terms of
of the specific time schedule for the
wfp you'd really really need to refrain
[Music]